well it's no secret so many of our
viewers are doing great things
all around the valley they are and we
have launched a segment to tell their
stories
it's eight points of community pride
this week we introduce you to metro
officer laura vilikana
she grew up here in the valley she tells
us getting the chance to work in the
northeast community where she grew up
is definitely something special for her
officer villicanas says she saw the need
to bring more neighbors together
and she came up with her own spin on the
traditional coffee with a cop
she calls it agua fresca with a cup
hopefully having more events like this
coffee with the cop citizens can see
that we're here for them we're
approachable
so any questions any concerns that they
have they can always come and talk to us
and then have a norchata if you've got a
story of our community coming together
please share it with us we like to
highlight those on fridays for for
information on how to do that just head
to our website eight 8newsnow.com